welcome back so in this short video I'm
going to talk about the art of the
possible in machine learning so
specifically trying to give you case
studies of the development of the
capabilities of machine learning over
the last 10 years and this kind of
moving goal post of what is easy medium
and hard in the field of machine
learning
so we call this the art of the possible
this is continually unfolding
continuously changing and what I'm going
to do is go through a number of little
vignettes and examples of problems that
used to be hard for machine learning and
now are easy and set up some of the
problems that are still hard that we
hope will be you know more possible to
solve more easily in the future so I'm
going to jump right in this is broadly
speaking we're talking about General
Topics in applications of machine
learning so image Sciences audio
sequences natural language processing
not so much engineering applications but
we'll get to those soon
so there there's this nice XKCD comic
you know when a user takes a photo the
app should check whether they're in a
national park this is an idea for an app
someone's thinking about
okay so the programmer says sure easy uh
you know geospatial lookup give me a few
hours okay so easy to tell from a photo
whether or not they're in a national
park
and the app should check whether the
photo is of a bird okay I'll need a
research team in five years so this is a
joke that
um you know some problems are trivially
easy if you have the right data if you
have this kind of geotag other tasks
might be full-on research level projects
you know five years and a team of
researchers
now what's funny
is that this comic is not that old and
when this comic was made telling whether
or not the photo has a bird and it was a
hard problem a hard research problem
that would need a team in five years now
telling if a photo has a bird and it is
trivially easy this is commodity
off-the-shelf machine learning it's in
all of our phones right now basically so
in a very short amount of time uh kind
of this meta this comic becomes more
interesting in that medicines but that's
really what I want to get to today is
what are things that are easy medium and
hard and things that are easy now might
have been hard only five years ago okay
so facial recognition and image
recognition in general is one of these
fields that in the last 10 years has
went from being kind of the frontier
challenge to being a solved problem uh
broadly speaking in machine learning so
you can very accurately tell uh if an
image has faces and you can classify who
those faces belong to so we just went to
our daughter's School Musical and my
wife held up her phone to take a picture
of all of the hundred people in the cast
and in real time immediately it saw from
this tiny tiny image which one was our
daughter and recognized her out of all
of these people in real time that's
essentially a solved task 10 years ago
that was the frontier of modern machine
learning research
um the reason this has essentially
become a solved problem is because of
the development of imagenet and the the
training of a deep neural network to
solve the imagenet classification
problem in the 2010 to 2012 time frame
where essentially and and what I want to
point out almost all of the attention
goes to the imagenet trained neural
network that actually classified all of
these images that essentially was a
neural network model to classify all of
these images into their various
categories in my opinion the real hero
of this revolution 10 years ago where we
got a human level classification
performance on with a machine learning
model was actually because of the
imagenet data set in 2009 so this was
feifei Lee's group
and essentially they put together this
very very large labeled training data
set
um I believe it was you know millions of
images thousands of categories many many
examples per category of hand labeled
training data that then enabled the
training of the imagenet neural network
and so both of these are important but
it all started with this painstakingly
meticulously labeled training data so I
think that's a really important thing
for us to remember is it usually all
starts with the data and then training
the model I would say you know the
neural network that built the classifier
was inevitable once that training data
set was on the market
now what has happened yeah why was this
possible in in the 2010 time frame to
make such a big leap in training neural
networks just a couple of years before
nobody was talking about neural networks
as a serious machine learning Paradigm
all of uh industrial machine learning
was essentially decision trees support
Vector machines things like that
frame
there was this rapid acceleration of
compute power especially parallelized
compute power in the form of graphics
processor units that are very well
suited for neural networks
there were dramatically better
algorithms to train and optimize the the
weights of these neural networks to fit
the training data in that time period
and a huge amount of Industry investment
into the open source software and
pipelines like tensorflow and Pi torch
again around
um you know around the last 10 years and
this culmination of a massive massive
increasingly large data sets high
performance Computing better algorithms
to train these models and Industry
investment have really been the Catalyst
that has caused this huge acceleration
of machine learning we've seen in the
last 10 years and this is where most
people would say that the modern era of
machine learning started was this
imagenet breakthrough in image
classification
there are still
issues with automated classifications so
you know the blueberry Chihuahua or the
Fried Chicken Dog are two kind of good
examples where you know maybe it's not
perfectly able to classify all of these
images but I would argue that you know
definitely humans don't have perfect
ability either okay and this is more uh
just a joke to show kind of things have
gotten so far that you really need to
look at edge cases before these
algorithms even remotely break down
so image classification was a major
breakthrough you know just over 10 years
ago surveillance then became a Target
because it's easy to classify images but
moving sequences of images movies it's a
lot more data so it's a lot more data
intensive to process that in real time
now surveillance is essentially a solved
problem it's easy to segment images in
real time into different components and
track objects and tell what changes and
what's novel things like that
um generative images was a big push in
the last 10 years as well so the left
column these are real images kind of the
left and third column are real images
and the second and fourth column are
computer generated
versions of those uh those categories so
these are all fake flowers fake
Harvesters and fake broccoli and unless
you look really closely and zoom in it
actually does a really good job of kind
of fooling at least your broad sense if
I look at it out of the corner of my eye
these do look like uh you know tractors
and Harvesters and things like that you
have to look closely before you can see
that they're actually not real and this
one's even better
this image is at least five years old
things have gotten way way better in the
meantime for image generation now we
have deep fakes you can completely
generate a fake uh movie of a person
that's pretty
um hard to tell fake from reality
and again about five years ago image
captioning
um became kind of an interesting topic
so you would show a picture to one of
these machine learning algorithms and it
would try to come up with a sentence
that summarized or captioned the image
and you can see here it does a really
good job man in black shirt playing
guitar it's definitely a man in a black
shirt playing a guitar construction
worker in Orange safety vest working on
road and so on and so forth
but in 2017 it wasn't perfect there were
plenty of examples where it failed
miserably this is not a young boy
holding a baseball bat this is the
ugliest cat I've ever seen and there is
no horse to speak of standing in the
middle of the road okay so not perfect
Circa 2017 but again in that last five
years something that was hard has become
dramatically easier to the point that
this is almost a solved problem and we
are now working on the inverse problem
so taking a prompt or a sentence machine
learning algorithms like Dolly can now
generate very very compelling original
images that fit that caption okay so
Dolly too I started playing around with
this you know over the summer just just
typing in random prompts and I didn't do
anything special to get these amazing
images So guitar monster
and a cat submarine Chimera these are
the images that Dolly generates just
from those prompts and I'll point out uh
there are two ends here because my old
laptop the N key stuck so I think that
the double n is essential for the
texture of this guitar monster
but all joking aside if you think about
how impressive this is right this is a
very cool artist rendition of a monster
playing the guitar notice that the
guitar is also a monster it's really a
guitar double n monster very very cool
so something that was Unthinkable five
years ago is now commodity right you can
you can uh log on to Dolly too and do
this yourself right now today I'm
currently I think you know it's very
very cheap to generate an image from a
text sequence so it used to be
impossible now it's easy
and this
this trend in pretty much all of image
Sciences so um this is actually from
2019 the Samsung uh skolkovo Institute
of Science and Technology collaboration
where they essentially showed you could
take a single still image like the Mona
Lisa and you could essentially do this
this transfer learning and and kind of
texture transfer where now you can make
this come to life as if the Mona Lisa
was speaking so 2019 pretty recent but
also a lot has happened since then
uh I like to think about this if I go
back in time I remember when Google came
out with their deep dream which was this
deep generative dream kind of before all
of this technology I just showed you
where it would make these really weird
pictures you could take an image and
kind of decompose it and recompose it so
it was made out of geckos or Lizards or
puppies or flowers and it Harkens back
this idea to this archim baldos La
Primavera so he was around in uh the
1600s he was in Emperor Rudolph the
second Court essentially supported by by
that dynasty and it's this really
interesting idea that you can decompose
a complex image into its abstract pieces
and now this is something that is
relatively standard capability with
machine learning is to transfer the
texture uh over so you could paint this
in the style of Van Gogh or any any
famous painter you like
and so we're thinking about this this is
kind of the deep dream of of this
archimbaldo's La Primavera by Calhoun
press I really like this if you actually
download this uh GIF and and pause the
frames you'll see that there are you
know different decompositions of this in
terms of like peacock feathers or
puppies or things like that
and so one of the open problems today
one of the things we're actively active
research that's hard today that we hope
is going to be easy in five or ten years
is the same idea of kind of texture
transfer we want to start applying to
physical systems like fluid flows and
Engineering Systems so here I have a
really uh low Reynolds number simple
simulation of a simple fluid flow past
an obstacle past a circular cylinder
this is our you know warm-up Benchmark
problem in fluid dynamics to compute
lift and drag and things like that
and with commodity off-the-shelf
algorithms you can do a texture transfer
I can re-paint this picture in the style
of famous artists and so that's easy
what we want to do is we want to repaint
this fluid flow in the texture of a much
higher Reynolds number fluid flow so
what I want to do is I want to know from
this base image what would the flow look
like if I cranked up the flow velocity
to something that is realistic for an
aircraft or if I cranked up the Mach
number to something that's realistic of
an aircraft that's much harder to do and
we not only want to do it so it looks
good to the eye we want it to be
quantitatively accurate as well so for
example we want you know Mass momentum
and energy to be conserved when we do
this style transfer and so that is
currently hard today but researchers
across the world are working on
solutions to do that for fluid flows for
materials for all kinds of physical
systems where we have both f equals ma
physics and we have lots of training
data where we might actually have
examples of this flow at low speed and
high speed to do that that transfer
pardon today hopefully not tomorrow
lots of other things that are difficult
for uh for computers so I
was showing you lots of image examples
there's also natural language and text
and speech and things like that so I
think the Next Great American novel is
going to be something that will be quite
challenging for an AI agent to generate
I think it's unlikely for a computer to
have the kind of deep insights into
society that for example F Scott
Fitzgerald could have had in his era
unless that AI has a body and has the
ability to go and interact
um that's not to say it can't generate
some types of fiction we don't know
um who knows maybe in five years this
will become much easier than I thought
it would be maybe it's still going to be
much harder than we thought it would be
we don't know but you know writing the
Next Great American novel I'm gonna be
um you know cautiously pessimistic about
that capability
this is actually a machine learning
generated fan fiction for Harry Potter
so they took a bunch they took all of
Harry Potter and they took a bunch of
fan fiction and basically generated an
algorithm that would generate new fan
fiction Harry Potter text
um it's not terrible it's not very good
but it's not terrible you can always
pause this and read some of the lines
are awful some of them are actually kind
of cute Ron's Ron shirt was just as bad
as Ron himself I don't hate that that's
not bad but you know there's still a
long way to go and this was a couple of
years ago
earlier than that it was shown that you
actually can use
um kind of these generative algorithms
to build fake conference papers academic
papers that would get accepted to top
journals and conferences and so it's
unclear to me if this says more about
the machine learning algorithms or more
about the state of academic publishing
but there are absolutely you know
anything that is really rigid and
formulaic and structured like writing an
academic paper you have more of a shot
of being able to automate and train an
algorithm to kind of recognize those
patterns and regenerate those patterns
examples just in a very recent time chat
GPT and large language models have kind
of revolutionized the art of the
possible dramatically advancing our
ability to generate human consistent
natural language in a way that is much
much faster than we thought would be
possible we being kind of the general
Community I think it surprised most of
us so here's a cool example I got from
from Bing Brunton there's this famous
Samuel Taylor College poem about Xanadu
and Xanadu did Kubla Khan a stately
pleasure Dome decree where Alf the
sacred River ran through Caverns
measureless to man down to a sunless sea
beautiful little stanza of a poem now
the way The Story Goes Samuel Taylor
Coleridge wrote this down just before
falling into an opium stupor and when he
woke up he couldn't remember the rest of
the poem so this is a famous unfinished
poem and lots of people have speculated
how this might go what it could have
been like
some researchers ran this through chat
GPT 3 and it actually completes the poem
in the stat the style of college
starting with this prompt and again it's
not perfect but it's really not bad at
all you can pause this and you can read
it yourself but this is a major
breakthrough these large language models
are a major breakthrough in the
capabilities of the art of possible with
with natural language processing and
human realistic generative text and this
is likely going to change
many many of our daily Pursuits right if
you want to write a technical manual
this can help write that technical
manual faster if you want to write unit
tests for your codes or Auto
documentation for your codes this is
going to help do that faster this is uh
helps us write emails faster auto
complete codes as a kind of co-pilot
tons and tons of things and we're just
scratching the surface of what these
large language models are capable of and
again this slide is only a couple of
months old already out of date right now
we're on to gpt4 and these are only
going to increase in their complexity
and sophistication in the years to come
so something that was really really hard
um
a couple of years ago now it's
accelerating at really rapid pace
okay large language models huge huge
field
moving to other systems I think this is
kind of interesting there is this more
of X Paradox which is it's easier to
build a Computing system that will beat
a human at chess than it is to actually
pick up the chess piece and move the
piece dexterously across the board so I
think there's an example of you know a
competition between a boy and a computer
chess agent and the computer chess agent
also had a robotic body that would move
the chess pieces
and
um at some point it accidentally broke
the kid's arm and you know that's how
the game ended not because it beat it at
chess but because it was so horrifically
bad at moving the pieces that it kind of
disqualified itself uh through gross
bodily harm
so things AI is good at it's good at
math it's good at games now it's very
good at language things it is not good
at yet are sensing and interacting with
the world and so there's this idea that
you know this kind of AI brain it
definitely is developing the
capabilities are advancing rapidly but
the kind of body side of things are not
advancing nearly as quickly robotics you
know super exciting area lots of
progress but the advances in the robotic
body are not happening as striking or as
fast as the advances in the the kind of
robotic mind and I think this is going
to be in the future a big distinction
is that there are certain things you
need to interact with the world to
gather the information to be curious to
really enrich your models Beyond math
games and language we'll see again
currently hard maybe in five years this
will be easier than we think it is
and there's a a lot of good examples of
machines being very very good at games
so 2015 there were these extremely
Advanced demonstrations of reinforcement
learning by deepmind essentially a deep
neural network Q learning algorithm
showed that it was possible
to play most old Atari games at or above
human level performance this was pretty
impressive so this is a classic game
I think it's called block out where
essentially it's like pong but it's a
one player pong and you're trying to
break this rainbow
array of Bricks by bouncing this this
dot back and forth
so you know after a few minutes of game
play it can play poorly but it can at
least you know hit the hit the ball with
the paddle you know moderately often
after two hours it is very reliably able
to position the paddle to hit the ball
and it's able to you know eventually get
a respectable score in this fairly
repetitive task game
um you know it's doing probably better
than I could do with a similar amount of
practice
what I think is remarkable though is
after four hours of training that's not
a lot of training right like when I was
a kid I would play four hours in one
sitting
it learned something that only expert
humans get which is that if it just
drills this left side here watch it it's
just really trying to focus on this left
side over here if it drills this left
side then the physics of the game take
over and solve the problem for it that
is in my opinion an actual kind of
interesting Innovative leap in the
learning process that's a form a weak
weak form of intelligence when you learn
kind of the physics of a system and how
to help it assist your goals
reinforcement learning in general is a
really exciting area lots of progress
this is not going as fast
as many of the other fields but you know
humans no longer can be computers at
chess or go because of reinforcement
learning reinforcement learning is
getting uh to the point where it can
help us in robotic scenarios as well in
robotic Control Systems so this is a
form of imitation learning
where essentially the robot is trying to
do this catch a ball in a cup maneuver
and with a little bit of human guidance
and a number of repetitions here's the
policy after 15 trials it can actually
do a decent job it can get close to
catching the ball in the cup
after 25 I think it's something like
after 50 or 100 trials it'll actually be
able to get the ball on the cup it's not
perfect yet but that's actually pretty
close to what I would call human level
learning rates if you give a ball and a
cup to a you know seven-year-old I bet
it's going to take them 50 or 100 times
before they reliably can learn how to
get the ball in the cup
now they're not going to have to be
against a white background with a high
resolution camera mounted perfectly
they're going to be able to do this
while they're you know walking down the
street or in a new environment but still
baby steps for the robot
and there's plenty of examples for every
example of a new Innovative
reinforcement learning algorithm
actually working on a game or on a robot
there are a million examples of things
failing this is 2015 so there has been a
ton of progress you know Boston Dynamics
is way better than it used to be
but robots are hard robots are one of
these uh very challenging cases
especially for machine learning we'll
talk about this later
systems like Boston Dynamics are largely
physics-based models painstakingly tuned
learning algorithms struggle in robotics
and in the last five years there have
been major advances so it's not all just
you know falling over when it tries to
open a door but I just want to remind us
that a very short time ago this was an
impossibly hard Challenge
and the field is moving very rapidly
it's getting a lot better but there's
still a long ways to go
good so we've covered images we've
covered language we've covered Robotics
and games I just want to point out there
are some things that are always going to
be hard they are mathematically hard and
there's no way around it so predicting
chaotic systems there are limits to what
we possibly can do regardless of how
good the model is to how well we can
predict uh the evolution of a chaotic
system like the path of a hurricane or
like what the weather is going to be
like next Thursday
these things are kind of hard by the
mathematics and the physics of the
situation and so there is a bound on how
good you can do given certain
measurement fidelities and things like
that
there's also caveats
sometimes there are unexpected
consequences to our machine learning
models and so this is just a kind of
cute example I found where you know on
Amazon let's say you want to buy
um
this item I'll let you imagine what this
item is and it automatically suggests
that you probably want magnesium ribbon
and aluminum powder in addition to this
item now I can tell you from my
checkered past that this is a suggestion
for the recipe to thermite so you know
and and the reason is is because this
was a pattern that was in the data
enough people that bought this were
actually going to make thermite that
this algorithm suggests for you hey
maybe you want to be making thermite
without thinking about the consequences
so there are certainly other dimensions
to this easy medium and hard there are
things like can we put you know uh guard
rails on these Technologies so that they
don't give us unethical or dangerous
Solutions this is especially topical now
in the chat GPT and large language model
realm where you know there are real
issues with having these language models
be as eloquent and compelling as a
skilled human what could go wrong with
that okay that's something we're working
on now
but I think that understanding just the
landscape and the context of what is
easy medium and hard how fast these have
changed over the last 10 years and what
are the current challenges we face today
I think that gives us a good chance of
understanding how we can use these
Technologies where we need to develop
these Technologies and what are some of
the ethical and kind of safety critical
ramifications of these Technologies
maybe just a parting thought for the
engineers in the audience for me one of
the big exciting Frontiers in this
machine learning research is taking all
of these technologies that have been
developed for things like image sciences
and language models and transferring
these over into the world of physics
systems governed by f equals m a systems
that have rules and guidelines like
aircraft or automobiles and you know for
me that's a really really exciting next
task is advancing machine learning to
solve scientific and Engineering
challenges so of course that's my
personal prerogative and that's where
you know my lab works on our research
but I think that is going to be a really
compelling set of examples in the next 5
10 20 years
all right thank you